let's talk about the good news and the
bad news from timcast.com the
economist's midterm model shows
republicans have a 74 percent chance of
winning the house democrats have a 78
chance of holding the senate
kind of sucks huh
yeah you definitely have to go vote is
what i'd say
people get so mad at me when i'm like
hey man a red wave is not guaranteed
they're like don't be a black pillar
don't be a dooms here i'm like oh i have
said it once i will say it again
i think conservatives can get complacent
i mean conservative not just republicans
but libertarians who even lean on the
conservative side like anybody who falls
in this scope they can be like well it's
close enough we'll just trust it's going
to happen that's not enough you have to
remain more active than that well i
think a lot of people are thinking like
okay if republicans do take control yes
that's better than democrats having
control but really what's going to
happen are there going to be a lot of
strongly worded letters or they're going
to be more like investigations that are
televised like what's really going to
happen what are republicans going to do
strongly worded letters yeah that's
about what they do they're really good
at that yeah print more money i think
they'll just keep printing money and
ignore the federal reserve yeah yeah
yeah sad that's what we already feel
like that's if all governments but this
is why they're freaking out so much
about the maga republicans because the
maga republicans actually are going to
do something mm-hmm they at least do
something yeah now the maga republicans
who do you think that joe biden is
thinking of do you think he's thinking
of like marjorie taylor green matt gates
those kind of people
yeah
and uh well but also look at the people
who are winning right when liz cheney
lost he probably cried
yeah you know him and him and all of his
democrat buddies were like no you know
our our spy
yeah we lost her but she is on the
subcommittee she is supposed to get
reelected
it's like
liz cheney is effectively a democrat and
that says so much about what the
democratic party has become
like they're supporting this woman is
just but i think that speaks to the fact
that they
a lot of left-leaning people want uh
consensus they want people to agree with
the stances that they have and
the idea that
their
that true policy and governing comes
from debate with people who believe
differently than you do and whose ideas
are different than yours uh isn't as
easy to
build consensus around right because it
involves conflict this is this is
similar to what 538 has there 538 saying
70 out of 100 simulations show democrats
winning the senate who connected this
one this is the economist
and think about how sad that is
that republicans were up in the generic
ballot and now democrats are back up the
republicans just don't know how to
campaign because no they don't
understand emotions
michael malz made a really good point
that democrats voted for this guy what
was his name mel in 2000 the missouri
senator guy you want to look him up he
died what's his name and they look it up
senator dies and gets elected he's in
2000.
democrat died and they still voted for
the guy and so he he was like republic
he said republicans going after
fetterman's health are making a mistake
because they don't understand totally
democrats have literally elected a dead
man and then the governor had to appoint
someone and appointed his widow to run
out way more often i mean this was uh
there's a podcast called missing alaska
talks about uh alas the last democratic
alaskan senator uh or congressman uh
nick begich and then hale boggs from
louisiana both went missing i believe
they weren't declared dead at the time
of their election but they were
definitely missing no one like their
plane blew up no one knows where it is
to this day they both got re-elected
hellbogs widow took over hit ran and
took over his seat
this uh his name is mel carnahan this is
phenom this i've never heard this before
tonight uh on november 7 2000 select the
next u.s center for missouri incumbent
republican senator john ashcroft ran for
reelection for a second term but he's
defeated by democratic governor mel
carnahan despite carnahan's death in a
plane crash three weeks before the
election day despite that
he died and then three weeks later
people hated the other guy so much they
still voted for the dead guy for the guy
who died for whatever reason come on
dude republicans
yeah i think that after the i think it
was the second debate between trump and
biden when trump just like would not let
biden
finish talking there was a lot of
sympathy i saw on social media for biden
it wasn't like oh he looks weak i think
people kind of wanted someone that was
weak which is really sad but i think a
lot of people do because of that
emotional piece well i think people get
the big criticism of trump is that he's
too aggressive he's too harsh and he's
moved too extreme so on the opposite
biden seems like this career polish you
know soft-spoken
uh incumbent
it's because he's old and i i really
fundamentally believe that like it
reminds me it's a mistake
you know of their grandfather yeah you
don't want somebody yelling at your
grandfather yeah it's kind of cute that
he takes a nap at 4 p.m and he can't
finish his sentences
well and it makes him hard to attack
because if you attack him you're like
you're attacking my grandpa yeah and
you're attacking like an elderly person
like that's weird he's nasty and he's
always been nasty yeah
um i
would love to see
republicans
see this poll
and become more motivated right
i think a lot this is sort of a
dangerous period for conservative
leaning voters because they'll be as
much as possible discouragement and
you'll see a lot of left-leaning press
say like well this this race is based
basically become unwinnable and like
you'll read the article that'll be the
headline they'll read the article and be
like well i don't i don't really know
that that's true
i think
that the red wave is not a guarantee i
think that it's definitely something
that you'd have to stay committed to as
voters but i also think that like they
the other side of the aisle would like
you to be discouraged i kind of feel
like when uh the the republican primary
in pennsylvania was happening
donald trump picked up his phone he's
like i'm going to be giving an
endorsement to a great candidate and
then right when the phone goes up to his
head
a squirrel dropped
an apple on his head he went don't ask
dr russ vote for him and then all of a
sudden the news press like the press
runs with it trump endorses oz and and
now republicans are going to lose
pennsylvania he thinks you think that
that i mean i know you don't literally
think that's what happened but i think
it's like yeah but i think it's very
true i think it's very trumpy i think
it's very trumpy to be like he's like
you were on tv and i was on board this
is my friend like him and hannity and dr
oz have been friends for a long time i
think that is what trump cares about far
more than any ideology and i will say
that
oz has
gained in the polls he's still trailing
but he's only like five points behind
fetterman now fetterman just agreed to
have a debate in mid-october i mean like
i think you know
maybe he can win it's like he could but
that's the thing like we feel like he
can't we're already counting
pennsylvania out and like i just feel
like it is too early to call even all of
this modeling you know
it will dramatically change so much
because we know the final basically six
weeks before the election can produce
some crazy changes did you see
fetterman's speech when he was bumbling
his words and saying the wrong stuff
like he had a stroke about a year ago
six months ago he had a stroke in may
and the day that he won the primary he
was actually undergoing surgery the guy
is messed up in the head right now he's
not equipped to run a state this is
freakish well so that's what pat toomey
said he endorsed oz before but then in
this recent coverage of like because he
at first um federer was like no i'm not
doing a debate like you guys are
bullying me and you are making fun of my
recovery and oz was seen as really
aggressive being like look if you want
to represent the state come out and
represent the state and then
recently pat toomey was like the thing
is if you're in congress you have to be
able to speak clearly you have to be
able to endure like you need to be able
to do this like it's actually not
unreasonable that there would there's he
would he should it would be reasonable
you would step down from congress if you
suffer a mind-altering stroke well they
should give him a bell
that he can have on his right hand that
he can ding and then the nurse can have
a list of the letters i've been watching
breaking bad a lot so no i mean like
i mean part of like what's hard about it
is so the uh oz campaign sorry i wrote
about this for timcast.com so i'm up to
date on this one uh uh the oz campaign
had offered him they had to like we want
to do five debates and we'll offer you
all kinds of accommodations you can have
an earpiece to talk to your staff we can
have more than one uh bathroom break you
can have something to sit on like and
the bathroom seems kind of insulting i
think it makes him feel like he's
geriatric and he was like no you guys
are like you guys are not respecting my
you're supposed to be a doctor and
you're not respecting my recovery it's
serious i'm getting better i'm getting
stronger but like this is insulting and
they held two the oz campaign held two
was like no you should have a debate
like it's traditional this is not i
think pennsylvania's been having debates
in the senate race since 2016. yeah uh
and
the oz campaign hasn't committed they
said it's gonna be mid-mid to late
october they won't say when but it's
this this back and forth we're like oz
seems aggressive and i think a lot of
republicans are like please stop don't
do that but at the other hand they're
producing results i mean he is getting
this debate which he said he wants well
he was on the defense i feel like oz was
on the defense for a long time like they
were trying to do funny like twitter
memes and that's just not going to work
it's snoopy fetterman had snooki in one
of his campaigns which was funny new
jersey that was really that was yeah and
it was funny like fetterman's social
media strategy has been good and he has
been most sorry but he's been mostly
virtual while he's been recovering from
a stroke right which has been good and i
think it's good that oz kind of decided
okay that's not going to be my game it
has actually kind of pressed him because
if you're not strong enough to debate
you're not strong enough to lead the
state
i feel like
fetterman is more likeable than dr oz
yeah and he's america's coolest mayor
says the guardian right you you take
politics out of it like i don't like the
democratic party and i don't like most
of the republican party but you take
politics out of it and you've got a dude
who's cracking jokes and wearing a
hoodie and then some doctor in a suit
talking about crudite and it's like
i don't know man i think that that's a
big factor because people voted for
barack obama because he was a celebrity
people voted for justin trudeau women
did because he was a hunk huh that was
like there was like a poll or something
came out right like the women were like
they voted for trudeau because he was
attractive must be canadian women well i
think a lot of people vote for
candidates because they're attractive
didn't trudeau do like a weird yoga
thing on his desk or something and then
trudeau is weird
i agree though he's a weirdo um but
that's what gets you votes man yeah well
and also like they have this hometown
boy versus like
no i mean no no no no i'm not saying
that i'm saying he's more he's more
relatable related for sure but he's been
i feel like he's been seating this i
mean he's lieutenant governor he's been
prepping for this race for a while uh he
was celebrated during cove but he did a
lot of stuff that people in pennsylvania
supposedly liked he was making the
rounds with his wife on like different
relationship podcasts talking about
their marriage and stuff like that uh
you know i i think
he has tried to prepare to be the most
likable candidate obviously
unpredictable that he had this stroke
right no one really could have seen this
one coming um but i do think that
he was the guaranteed winner of the
democratic primary for a long time which
made it much harder to calculate who he
was going to be up against and
the
i think the hardest criticism that i
hear of oz is that he's maybe from new
jersey or something and that's maybe not
enough for pennsylvania voters and he
was like
pro
transiting the kids a few years ago
maybe not pro but he platformed it on a
show and he was anti-second amendment so
that was my big that was my thing also i
didn't like the primary against kathy
barnett when he had all of these like
republican trolls coming out against
kathy barnett and just started lying
about her for the sake of he has been
running a super aggressive campaign it's
wild you know regarding fetterman's rise
to power what he's been doing he's been
working at this his whole life he's been
aiming at this his whole life i have
compassion for someone that is about to
run the race of their life and they
break their ankle but you don't run the
race in those situations if your ankle's
busted i have compassion but not to a
fault like what you're talking about
earlier that's dangerous if you want to
love some ill person and let them run
your life you're going to die that's
that's the result of it you have to make
the best healthiest person in charge
they've they've elected dead people yeah
they've literally we are in a breaking
point this is
this is it this is the moment when the
world is looking at us to lead i um
you know in in in a hard
idealistic sense i actually think voting
for the dead person is the better thing
to do because then you have no one in
that chair screwing everything up the
problem is in real life
they just appoint someone to fill the
seat so you're voting for nobody you're
voting for the governor to just be able
to put in whoever they want which if you
live in a state where the governor's in
your party and you trust him is why you
would do that right so if you are in a
blue state and your democratic person
dies or goes missing and you think that
the governor will appoint another
democrat to fill the spot like yeah you
cause you cast your ballot along party
lines i love that meme that's uh you've
probably seen it says vote nobody
nobody supports the people nobody cares
about the working class no nobody will
fight corruption nobody cares about you
vote for nobody that's right and it's
like that's a great meme there you go
yeah but you know it's a bit jaded i
think we've got some good maga
republicans who are uh who are in
congress who are running
are you fan of marjorie taylor-green
forcing the floor votes that's such a
fantastic move i tweeted this out and i
wonder what you guys think do do you
need political zealots to run a
government
no
what do you mean do you need in order to
fight in order to run a government to
have a government function do you need
political zealots involved people that
you know love politics that want to
politic and talk i think people have to
want to be a public officer in america i
don't think someone who is unwilling can
sustain the lifestyle right but i also
think that we forget we see the elected
official and we forget that they have
advisors and staff and other people who
are helping write their policies like
there are a lot of ways to be involved
with influencing uh politics in the
government you don't have to just be the
person on the poster re-election bothers
me because people shouldn't be in and
thinking about their next term that
should never never even remotely be part
of it they should just be allowed to be
what if they get in they do the job
they're four years and they're out all
right
well what if they're really good and you
want them to come back thank you start a
business and i'll follow you on
instagram but what if i thought they
were putting out good policies and i
want them to stay keep talking about
your policies on twitter and i'll follow
you but you're done in politics after
that but then you create shadow
governments we already have shadow
governments we're making them worse i
don't think so man if you want to say
this is a we have a government here and
that you're a governor of people's minds
then yeah maybe
but like there is power to social media
and socializing and getting cults of
people to do what you say
maybe what happens is you know like
someone gets elected to a first term
right
and then we don't have to worry about
reelection because we just make it a
lifetime appointment and then you gotta
you gotta worry about what happens after
that well it's simple we just have
whatever position they had transferred
to their children or the for the first
boy oh that's perfect yeah there you go
and then you know
and then you don't gotta worry about
re-elections and then what we'll do is
if they don't have kids we eliminate the
position and then you know eventually
it's gonna make everything way easier
yeah there's just one person who
inherits the we'll call it a throne
and then they're in charge and then when
they die their kid takes over and just
one person this is novel i wonder if no
one has thought of that yeah super
simple it seems like and then no one's
gonna worry about re-election
no term limits none of that just there
you go i think i want my politicians to
be thinking about their re-election i
want them to be thinking about their
next term don't do that i'm not going to
vote for you i want them to be scared i
think term limits if you have term
limits and they know that they're out of
office no matter what why do they have
to listen to what their voters or
constituents want why do they have to
care because they want to survive after
they're out of office you're saying
people will attack them oh well kelly i
didn't say that if you go into office
and you betray and destroy people's
lives you better run for your life i
mean you're that's not a good position
to be human
i don't want the consequence to be look
at the issue of humanity congressional
approval what's the congressional
approval rating 17
no one likes these people
well i'm talking worst case scenario if
a leader goes in and rapes and pillages
his population they're not like look at
libya look at what they did to muammar
qaddafi i don't want him but i don't
know what i'm talking about airstrikes
i'm just talking about hillary clinton i
mean there are already politicians that
go in and betray their constituents all
the time if they don't get killed lis
cheney is out of office but she's not
dead well they're not really
i mean
they're not betraying people i don't
think the politicians have really i mean
they're
maybe maybe them siphoning off our
wealth as a form of betrayal but yeah i
certainly think i don't feel like well
they're making things worse it just
doesn't feel like they're making things
better thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there